oh here was the question somebody in our
office wanted to know the answer to who
smells better in person Peter or Tyler
Peter interesting how so what does he
smell like smells very fresh fresh
where's fresh guy what is Tyler smelling
dogs
super manly man doesn't it smell bad
they both smell good it's different
Bud's a more rugged scent versus a more
poverty thing like sweat just crushed
singing the song my cup might say rosy
but it's tea today
Oh have a sip and the reason we have you
guys here today is to play sip or spill
our new roses and roses a game where I'm
gonna ask you questions and you can
either spit but see an answer or take a
scent because you want to stay discreet
so thank you so much for being here
let's start with a little teach Yas
pinkies up she has sherry and Hannah and
I have some beautiful beautiful teacups
Dylan I wanted to keep things more manly
for you but your mug does still have
pink writing and it says you've got this
you've got this guy's empowerment okay
are you ready to play sick horse pill we
are beginning with some bachelor nation
related questions if you could play
cupid for two people in bachelor nation
who would it be would you guys like to
ship who should start dating that's a
good way that's a good one thank you
I feel like Dylan has an answer he's not
saying it yeah do you got one yes who
well I'm thinking so maybe like I
Dean and Connery Oh Connor that's a good
one
oh they're both they might experiment
well I I'm just I don't know what they
were gonna do you asked me who I would
ship okay but Dean and Kalyn are dating
right now this is an alternate universe
oh we liked eating Caitlyn together okay
yeah I didn't know if you were taking me
down a dark road going no no there's a
happy Road I just want to say first two
names that come to mind first is ready
set go
Connor and 300 both very tall very tall
I like that too tall
no it's got a lot going on it's like
rows a and T but a Beyonce not gonna
Chuck's lotta boxes for me all right sip
or spill who should Tyler Cameron date
you guys have met a lot of people in
bachelor nation at this point now who
made the best first impression that
you've met who did you love instantly
Dean seed yeah yes how come Dean what
Hannah first but then obviously but then
Dean I Dean showed up with a mustache
yeah in shorts and like who does that
Annie is an Instagram tattoo
like the logo on his thighs the funniest
thing I've ever seen okay
he went permanent on that he's verified
for life I did not know that and did we
see that in paradise or didn't blurt
house that's like no sponsorship here
who made the worst first impression
Julian you're very discreet
Hannah's thinking it might be somebody
you could have had a bad first
impression and now you're cool but did
anybody have an awkward or weird first
impression to you I don't okay it wasn't
a bad impression it was actually a good
one but it like I remember I would the
first time I ever met
Demi I was so scared of her because she
had such a strong presence yeah but then
I was like the next day I was obsessed
with her or even that later that day I
was like I'm obsessed with you I love it
took mere hours yeah who is currently
holding the title as the biggest diva in
bachelor nation Dylan you're never again
you're doing this really cute thing
Dylan where you are looking to Hannah
for every answer it's the most couple
thing I've ever seen he's like what are
we saying can I say are you a diva I'm
not a diva I'm it can be it comes out
sometimes it comes out if it's hot
outside Oh like warm well on hot weather
yeah I'm like 73 or if I'm hungry
that's why I had to eat before I could
so Dean needs to be comfortable we're
doing Dean also needs to be comfortable
the most embarrassing moment for you to
watch yourself back on television we're
when we're out the finale we go with
Chris Paradise Valley we're up in our
little hot seat and a booger fell on my
nose for everybody it didn't air her I'm
not kidding
I've never laughed so hard it was our
first time as an engaged couple going to
talk to Chris right and you know we're
sitting there and I kind of out of the
corner of my eye I'm answering a
question and Dylan is like picking his
nose
receive over and you said I think
there's a booger in my nose baby
breathes and it did and it felt right
Chris was like I'm sure he was like what
are they doing right now and I flicked
it off but and that's love we're just
kind of there's to that Cheers cheers to
that it must have been quite a dry
booger to just fall out you guys got
engaged on paradise which other Paradise
couple or bachelor nation couple do you
predict we'll get engaged next I don't
know if Dean and Kahlan will soon but I
anytime they go on like a cute fun trip
I'm like kind of in the back of my mind
hoping for it or something but I mean I
think they're just like taking it slow
doing them I love following doing
Kaitlyn you see Dean being ready for
that I don't know about Dean it's up to
him you should really go into politics
dawn these are very good political
answer thank you but they're constantly
in these romantic settings like on top
of a mountain yeah ever like it would
always be a perfect moment to propose
yeah I see that
Oh will we see you back on your screens
would you guys do reality TV again uh
Hanna wants to do Dancing with the Stars
uh I mean no I
okay wait he puts me in weird situations
wait what another Hannah another Hannah
do you want to do it would you mean okay
I mean maybe but it's enough we've never
even talked about that before so but I
don't know I thought clicking show yeah
would you get married on TV um I don't
really think that's in the plans right
now we have to be kind of small and like
intimate with our family one thing that
we talked about sweet showed a lot of
ourselves I'm paradise and I kind of
want to circle back with with those that
mean the most to us oh okay well that's
a great transition into my next set of
questions at all about your love for
each other so you've talked about your
wedding yes
okay every day today at length probably
six hours day done you're so dry yeah
just like your boogers it's hard to tell
so you guys have talked to wedding plans
a little bit got some ideas going yeah
it's fun to talk about
we like nothing like concrete
bachelor nation is definitely getting an
invite I would say like triple hdk which
is like me Hannah
Heather Katie and Demi so it's like we
call ourselves Triple H okay we have a
group checks called that so it's like
really like a wrestling sounding like
very mistress that's a crew of course to
be rockin around you know in definitely
getting an invite for your crew Oh your
group text I would say Mike Mike brings
a lot of energy that's what I definitely
want sip or spill are you ready for kids
like today take the question how you
will not today today have you guys
talked about kids like baby names number
of kids if you have those conversations
slightly but only just like chatting
randomly we do have a dog name which I
think we should don't say it you were
gonna so we definitely want to get a dog
okay well if you're getting a dog
together does that mean moving in
together soon I think we're just
focusing on kind of being engaged and
hands crushing it in LA I'm in San Diego
and we're just gonna take every day
becomes tough god I can't wait for you
to run for president you're doing the
long-distance thing what is the most
important factor in your relationship
success and how happy this star yeah I
think we just placed our relationship
above everything else so we make it an
an effort to each other probably three
to four days a week and talked every day
non-stop so we never go to sleep like
angry or mad it's just like always like
putting out on the table even if it
doesn't sound great just like how we
feel I feel like that's been good okay
love all right some quickfire
relationship questions who is the better
cook
don't Hanna do you know how to say yogi
yet little easy dinner living this
cauliflower no no keep no that was good
no keep no mmm we're out on that if
you're a good cook ye shall /
I was I was busy and then I like open up
my phone I fifty text message like dude
what is going on in Hannah's story right
now and I sent it to him well like
literally after it was up for like five
minutes every single message like dying
laughing and I was like why are they
laughing I had no clue I know I was
maybe not totally saying it right but
the worst was that you like you like
highlighted it with your fingers good
not like you Brandon across I still I
still think an honest man okay yoky you
know right yeah perfect I'm saying it
wrong are there any other words you've
discovered over the years that you were
saying wrong and didn't know it it's
constant oh okay like what could Kijana
cheese good job but it's I think good to
you oh yes what is it but I really like
oh they have Kijana cheese on the bowl
yeah I'm like what cheese is that I see
a lot of things wrong
who is Messier hmm he's like looking at
me like he doesn't want to say you but
it's just my suitcase my suitcase is
always a struggle but my well that was a
good comedy stuff thank you crushed it
who needs to have the last word if you
do disagree I think you probably won it
but I you got it it doesn't seem like
you fight very much no not really it's
more like joking and if we're like I
feel like if we've ever had a
disagreement it's like we end up
laughing at the end of it just because
really this is going know something you
just say a word wrong and like what
you're like gnocchi you just talk
through it yeah we really it's like the
most unedited way coming out of our
mouths
whatever we have okay so you say it good
you guys can say it who cries more I'll
say it I was like you guys there's no
other couple where I felt so confident
that I wouldn't necessarily know the
answer like I don't know why I see you
you're a sensitive guy Dylan I don't
know I was like I could see don't you
say more no I thought you would maybe
cry more outside looking in you just
think oh that dude he definitely cries
yeah are you at the face speaking of
curious are you at the phase where you
fart in front of each other on accident
yeah both of us no not me no really
farther no I haven't no I'm actually
pulled the covers over my head he's
lying
oh my god Hannah Doan don't you guys
don't you know his humor everybody in
the room you guys dry dry as a booger
who wants to make out more like who just
loves why do you love PDA so much what
it's it's not the fact that it's PDA I
just like I'd like I'm in my own little
world have you always been like this or
is it it's just this lady yeah yes well
my next question might be answering
itself but we wanted to know Dylan are
you just as clingy to Hannah now as you
sort of infamously were in paradise
or like has it eased off a little bit
now that she's definitely your girl are
you sipping it are you gonna are you
just thirsty hi
probably both I wasn't clingy that's a
word that we think is funny because I
don't think he was a triggering word
it's not triggering as we get it oh here
come the tears I'm just as all over her
and okay in love with her as that was
well that's what I wondered like was it
just was that the phase of your
relationship and now you're a little
more so elder like goes no okay you're
just you're like I'm so into this woman
yeah Wow great
cheers to that cheers hey cheers sip or
spell what's the sexiest thing the other
person has ever done in front of you
answer how you will well now I feel like
a okay but you got no I got nothing I
think just you're very very thoughtful
is that sexy yeah noted women like
thoughtfulness thoughtfulness is sexy I
agree with the others thank you guys we
cannot wait to see your dear friend
Peter Webber on the new season of The
Bachelor is there any way we could see
you guys we can make any cameos on The
Bachelor yeah maybe alright it premieres
in January of course followed Dylan and
Hannah on Instagram for adorable content
that could include thoughtful gifts or
dry boogers thank you guys so much for
being here
bye
[Music]